The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: --
10 seconds to answer the
first clicker question.
As you can see we're having
another competition today, so
see if you can beat out Justin's
recitation and get
the most correct today.
So, this is a topic from Friday,
which is asking us
which of the following
molecules are
free radical species.
OK.
So it looks like most and you
got it, that it's o h.
Let's quickly go over why that
is just in case you weren't
one of that 74%.
So, if we're looking at o h
versus c o, what are we
looking at to decide if we
have a radical here?
Valence electrons.
So we have 6 plus 1 in terms
of o h, that's 7, versus
having 4 plus 6, which is 10.
Specifically, what
do we look for in
terms of valence electrons?
Odd numbers.
So, we have a radical here with
o h, whereas we have an
even number of valence electrons
for c o, so that's
not a radical, in terms of
what we know how to think
about so far, which is using
our Lewis structures to
determine that.
All right.
So that's a little review from
Friday, let's move on to
today's lecture.
In terms of what we're going
to be talking about today,
we're going to finish up with
talking about polar covalent
bonds, and finish up
with discussing the
idea of polar molecules.
And then we'll move on to start
talking about well, we
know how to draw our Lewis
structures, how can we use
those Lewis structures to think
about the actual shapes
of molecules.
So, first thinking about our
polar covalent bonds.
What we had established is if we
have a case where we have a
covalent bond, but there's
unequal sharing of electrons
between the two atoms, namely
because they have different
electronegativities, what we see
is we have a polar bond or
a polar covalent bond where one
of the atoms is going to
pull away more of the electron
density from that bond, giving
it that partial negative charge
where the other atom is
going to end up with a partial
positive charge.
In terms of thinking about
well, what do we call a
covalent bond versus a polar
covalent bond versus a purely
ionic bond, it turns out that
the distinction is a little
bit fuzzy, it's not a clear
line, but in terms of talking
about things in general, and
especially in thinking about
problems for this course, what
we're going to say is if you
have an electronegativity or chi
difference between the two
atoms that is greater than 0 .
4, and less than 1 .
7, and we're talking about the
Pauling electronegativity
scale here, which is what's
used throughout your book.
If you have a difference in
electronegativity anywhere in
that range, we'll have what we
call a polar covalent bond
between those two atoms.
So, for example, if we compare
the chi values for hydrogen
versus carbon, we see
they only have a
difference of 0.4 .
0.4 is not greater than 0.4 .
So we would not call this a c h
bond, we would not say it's
polar covalent, we would
just call it covalent.
In contrast, if we talk about
a carbon oxygen bond, now we
have a chi difference of 0.8 ,
so that is greater than 0.4 ,
so we'll call carbon oxygen
bond polar covalent.
We can extend this idea of
talking about these polar
covalent bonds to thinking
about an entire molecule.
I'm sure you've all heard of
the term a polar molecule
versus a non-polar molecule, and
essentially, when we talk
about having a polar molecule,
what we're saying is that
there's is a net non-zero
dipole moment
within the whole molecule.
So essentially, what we have
to do is combine all of the
individual bonds to think about
the molecule as a whole.
So, let's take an example of
carbon dioxide here, or c o 2.
Very soon in the lecture you'll
learn how to predict
shapes based on Lewis
structures.
So you will quickly see that
this is a linear molecule.
We can think about the
2 bonds within it.
There's two carbon oxygen bonds,
and we know that there
is a dipole in that
bond, which is
going toward the oxygen.
Remember, in chemistry we always
draw the arrow, we're
always interested in what those
electrons are doing.
So if we draw in the bond
dipoles, and you can draw
these into your notes, you want
to draw an arrow towards
the oxygen in each case.
But we're not just interested
here in thinking about do we
have a polar bond, we actually
want to know in general do we
have a polar molecule.
So, looking at c o 2 as a whole,
do you think we have a
polar or a non-polar
molecule here?
Non-polar.
OK, very good for all of you
that said non-polar.
The reason it's non-polar is
we simply have two equal
vectors in opposite directions,
so they cancel
each other out.
The net effect is that
we have a 0 dipole
moment in the c o molecule.
In contrast, we can
look at h 2 o.
H 2 o actually has this bent
shape, and again, we'll see
very soon and how to predict
that h 2 o has a bent shape,
that water is bent.
And again, we do have dipole
moments -- we have bonds where
there is a polar bond and we
should point our arrow toward
the oxygen, because electron
density is being pulled from
the hydrogen atoms
to the oxygen.
And again, we can cancel some
of these vectors out, but we
still have a net dipole moment
that is going to be going up
if we think about combining
these 2 vectors here.
So, what we would say, which
is what we know from
everything we've always
heard, which is that
water is a polar molecule.
So, this is a great
way to think about
molecules in general.
It's very easy to think about
if those vectors cancel each
other out or if they're additive
when we're talking
about just single bonds, so we
have two atoms or if we have
just three atoms, as we do
in these cases here.
But it turns out, a lot of the
molecules we consider are
actually much, much,
much larger than
just a couple of atoms.
So we can't often think about
canceling all the different
vectors out.
And in general, when we're
talking about these really
large molecules, whether
they're large organic
molecules or we're talking about
proteins, which can have
thousands of atoms in them,
instead of adding up all those
individual polar bonds, what
we do is we talk about the
number of polar groups that it
will have in the molecule.
So we can think about a protein,
for example, as
having a lot of different polar
groups or one that has
not too many polar
side groups.
That's one way you hear people
talking about proteins, and
that has a lot to do with their
solubility in water, and
also about how the protein's
going to fold.
But let's look at a little bit
about less complicated example
than a protein with thousands
of different atoms.
Let's instead consider a couple
of vitamins here, which
instead have a few dozen
different atoms in them.
Specifically, let's look at
vitamin A and vitamin B9.
Does anyone know another
name for vitamin B9?
I don't think I hear it -- does
anyone say folic acid.
It's also sometimes called
vitamin M. It's one of the
vitamin B9 vitamins, there's
actually other forms of
vitamin B9, but this is
one of the big ones
that you hear about.
Hopefully you're all very
familiar with folic acid,
because it's an important
vitamin to take, especially if
you're a woman, especially if
there's any chance you ever
might become pregnant in any
kind of near future time, by
accident or on purpose.
And the reason for this is
because folic acid deficiency
in pregnant women leads to
neural tube defects in babies,
and your brain develops very,
very, very early in pregnancy,
the brain of an embryo.
So it turns out that a lot of
women don't realize they're
pregnant while the fetus' brain
is developing, and if
these women are not getting
enough folic acid, you can end
up with spina bifida, which is
an absolutely devastating and
very preventable disease or
other neural tube defects.
So hopefully, if you're not
familiar with folic acid,
you'll become familiar at least
within the next 10 or 15
years or so before you're
thinking about maybe, on
purpose, becoming pregnant
at some time.
Vitamin A you probably all
heard about growing up,
getting enough of your carrots
so you can see at night.
Vitamin A is important
for eye health.
But just looking at the
structure of these two
molecules, knowing what we
know so far about general
chemistry, we can already say
a lot about how these are
going to function the body
or how they'll be
treated in the body.
And specifically, let's take a
look at which of these two
molecules has more polar bonds
and see what that tells us.
So take a look at your two
structures and tell me which
has, between folic acid and
vitamin A, more polar groups
within the vitamin.
And this should go pretty
quickly since you don't need
to have an exact number, we're
just looking and glancing and
seeing which has more.
So let's take 10 seconds
on this.
All right, great.
So most you said folic acid or
vitamin B9, so let's switch
back to our notes and
take a look at why.
So vitamin B9 has more
polar bonds.
It's very easy to see, once I
highlight, that it's not even
a close call at all.
We have a bunch of different
polar bonds in B9 versus just
one in vitamin A. Remember, the
c h bond we're not calling
polar covalent because it only
has an electronegativity
difference of 0.4 between
the two atoms.
So what we know is that vitamin
B9, folic acid, is
more polar.
Remember, we also just said that
water is polar, so would
we say that B9 is water
or fat soluble?
It's going to be water soluble
-- everyone knows the saying,
"like dissolves like."
B9 is going to
be very water soluble.
This actually is very important
if you think about
taking your vitamins.
This means if it's water
soluble, any vitamins that are
water soluble, and now you
should to be able to look at
the structure of any vitamin and
tell me, for example, that
vitamin C is water soluble,
that folic
acid is water soluble.
If you take these vitamins, what
happens is that they're
very quickly and easily excreted
into your urine.
So, for example, some people
like to take mega doses of
vitamin C. What really happens
is that you have a mega dose
of vitamin C in your urine,
it doesn't stick around
long in your body.
So it doesn't help and
just take all of your
vitamin C at once.
That's why it's important to eat
balanced meals throughout
the day, you need to be getting
a constant supply of
these water soluble vitamins.
The same is for folic acid, you
can't just take it once a
month, you need to be taking it
regularly in order that you
keep the stores up in your body,
otherwise you're going
to excrete it, you're going to
get rid of it very quickly.
In contrast, if we think about
vitamin A, is this going to be
water soluble or fat soluble?
Yup, so this is the fat
soluble vitamin.
Vitamin E is another big one
that's fat soluble that gets a
lot of press in terms of being
an important vitamin to take.
We can think about what it means
when a vitamin is fat
soluble instead of
water soluble.
Well, now it's not going to get
excreted out of our body
so quickly, so we actually can
build up amounts of vitamin A
vitamin E, for example, but that
can also pose a problem
if you think about biologically
what's happening.
And up here I just show two
different supplements that I
found on the internet.
This is One A Day vitamin, it
has about 100% of what you
need of everything.
And then this vitamin is one
that I found that's supposed
to really help you with your
eye health, if you have bad
vision instead of glasses, they
suggest that you try this
vitamin here.
And what you can see is that it
has five times your daily
value of vitamin A, and 13 times
what you need of vitamin
E. Is this a good idea?
No.
Basically, you are just building
up more and more and
more of these fat soluble
vitamins into your body.
And there have been studies that
have come out recently
trying to look at the health
benefits of vitamin E, and in
some of these studies they give
these mega doses, and
instead what they find is
increased bleeding in these
patients, an increase in overall
different types of
death that can be happening.
You want to take your vitamins,
it's very important,
but you don't want it just
build up, and you want to
think about is the vitamin that
I'm going and getting 800
times what I need a day, is that
a water soluble vitamin
or a fat soluble vitamin, and
using your chemistry, you
should be able to very quickly
take a quick look at that
structure and figure out what
kind of a vitamin that is.
All right.
So that's just one reason we
would want to be able to think
about polarity is thinking about
whether something is
very water soluble or not.
Let's think about some other
things that have to do with
polarity and then can tell us
a lot of other information.
So let's move on to talking
about the shapes of molecules.
And the shapes of molecules is
very important for a number of
different properties when we're
thinking about chemical
reactions and reactions that
take place in the body.
When we talk about shapes of
molecules, we're talking about
the geometry of that molecule.
And the geometry influences
all of its different
properties, including things
like melting point or boiling
point, it's reactivity.
We just saw when talking about
polar molecules, that it
influences whether or
not the molecule
itself is polar or apolar.
It's also really important when
we talk about biology.
Shape is particularly important
when you think about
enzymes having an active site
where a molecule needs to fit
perfectly into the active
site, it does that
because of its shape.
A quick example that we can
think about is with sucrose.
Does anyone know what
sucrose is?
It's just table sugar -- sucrose
is that crystal in
sugar that we hopefully use in
most of our sugar intake as
sweeteners.
A lot of times we use corn
syrup, which is often not
sucrose and which tends to be
not always as good for us,
although anything in too much
excess is obviously a
non-ideal situation.
But in order for us to use the
energy from sucrose, sucrose
is made up of two individual
sugar monomers.
It's made up of a monomer of
glucose and one of fructose, a
6 and a 5 membered ring, so in
order for our body to use it,
we need to break it into
with its monomers.
And if we that, we can do it by
what's called hydrolysis --
sucrose and water breaks down
into its two monomers, now our
body can use it.
The problem is this process
takes on the order of 10 or
maybe 100 years in order for us
to get enough of the sugar
broken down.
That's why we need an enzyme
molecule, and the enzyme in
our body is called sucrase.
Sucrase breaks down sucrose, it
catalyzes that reaction, so
it happens very quickly.
And the key is, and here's a
ball and stick shape of what
sucrose looks like.
It needs to fit exactly
into that active site.
When it does, it combines into
the enzyme, the enzyme can
then catalyze the hydrolysis or
the breaking apart of those
two individual monomers into
its separate pieces.
And then it let's go of the
glucose and the fructose, and
we get our enzyme back again,
and something else combined
into that active site.
So, this is one very simple
example of why molecular shape
is very important.
A lot of times you're thinking
about small molecules
interacting with proteins or
interacting with other
molecules, and you want to think
about the shape of that
molecule to think about how that
interaction is going to
take place.
So what we're going to use to
think about molecular shape or
molecular geometry is what's
called valence shell electron
repulsion or vsper theory.
And this theory is very
convenient for us to be
thinking about because we are
now masters of drawing Lewis
structures, and vesper theory is
based on Lewis structures,
and also the principle that when
we have valence electron
pairs, they're going to
repel each other.
This make sense any time you
have negatively-charged
electrons, you want to get them
as far away from each
other as possible
because they're
all negatively charged.
And the other principle is that
the geometry around that
central atom, which you've
identified as the central atom
in the Lewis structure, is
going to be such that it
minimizes the repulsion between
those either bonding
electrons or the
electron pairs.
So when we talk about vsper
there's a special nomenclature
that we do use, and in vsper we
have a -- does anyone know
what a means in vsper theory?
It's a central atom.
What about x?
So this is actually the
bonding, any bonding
atom you call x.
And then we have e, which
is equal to lone pairs.
So e is a lone pair -- e is not
a lone pair electron, so
if you have two electrons,
that's one lone pair.
All right.
So there are some guidelines
that we use when we're coming
up with these vsper
geometries.
The first thing we talk about is
the steric number, which we
use to predict what that
geometry will be.
When we're talking about steric
number, all we're
talking about is adding together
the number we have of
bonded atoms, plus the
number of lone pairs.
So, essentially were just adding
x to e and that gives
us our steric number.
So, for example, if we look at
this molecule, which is a x 2
e, what is the steric
number here?
Yeah, it's 3, so we have
a steric number of 3.
Something that I want to point
out is that we could have a
different molecule, which is
also a x 2 e, but in this case
we have a double bond between
the central atom and one of
the x atoms here, and what I
want to point out is in vsper
theory we treat bonds as bonds,
we don't worry about if
they're single or they're double
or they're triple.
So again, we call this a x 2
e, this again, has a steric
number of 3.
So what's important in terms of
vsper theory is the number
of atoms bonded to
a central atom.
What's not important is the
types of bonds that we're
dealing with.
A few other guidelines I want to
mention is first of all, to
think about resonance
structures.
So on Friday we were talking
about the chromate anion, and
we said that here are two of its
resonance structures here,
but that we could actually
draw four more resonance
structures, and I just want to
point out when you take a
molecule that has many different
resonance structures
and you want to draw its vsper,
it's Lewis structure
and its vsper geometry, you
can take any single one of
those resonance structures, it
doesn't matter, you'll all end
up with the same geometry.
And lastly, if we're talking
about a molecule that has more
than one central atom, which is
what we're very, very often
doing, you need to deal with
each one separately.
So for example, with methanol
here, we have a carbon, which
is a central atom, and we also
have an oxygen, which is a
central atom, you need to talk
about the geometry separately,
we don't talk about
the geometry
of the entire molecule.
So, let's go ahead and look at
some of these vsper examples,
and Professor Drennan is going
to help demonstrate what some
of these are with some
models here.
So the first case we're going
to talk about is without any
lone pairs -- this is the most
straightforward case.
And our first case that we can
have is a x 3, which is going
to have a linear shape, and that
will have a bond angle of
a 180 degrees.
The next case that we can
talk about is trigonal
planar or a x 3.
Now, you do need to know
these geometry, you
need to know the names.
A lot of them are very
easy to remember.
I expect not too many of you
will get linear incorrect.
Also, trigonal planar,
pretty easy.
Trigonal, it has 3 atoms around
the central atom and
the molecule is planar.
PROFESSOR: So, what is the bond
angle for this geometry?
120.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Great.
So, next we can think about a x
4, and this is what's called
a tetrahedral geometry.
If you're trying to remember
this name you can think of
each of those bonding atoms
as being in the corner of
tetrahedron.
One thing I want to point out is
you're seeing some notation
we haven't used before in this
class where you have a wedge
coming out at you, and you also
have a dashed line to one
of those bonds.
Any time you see a wedge in a
Lewis structure, it means that
it's coming out at you -- it's
either coming out of the
screen or it's coming
out of your paper.
And any time you see a dashed
line here, which might be
easier to see in your notes,
that means that the bond is
actually going into the page or
into the screen or into the
blackboard.
PROFESSOR: And what are the
angles for a tetrahedral?
PROFESSOR: All right,
so they're 1 0 9 .
5.
Pretty close.
So that's as far away as those
bonds can get from each other
would be 109 .
5 degrees.
The next case we
have is a x 5.
That is what we call trigonal
bipyramidal.
Again, we have trigonal, because
we have those 3 bonds
in the center, and if you can
picture putting walls between
all those bonds, you can see
there's a pyramid on the top
and a pyramid on the bottom,
so bipyramidal.
PROFESSOR: And there are 2 sets
of angles here, what are
the angles for equatorial
atoms?
120.
And then for axial?
90.
PROFESSOR: And again, axial,
those are just the ones in the
axis, and equatorial
if you put your
globe around the equator.
So the last case we
have is a x 6.
A x 6 is what we call octahedral
-- you can picture
each of those bonded atoms as
a corner of an octahedron.
PROFESSOR: And what are
the angles in this,
this one set of angles?
90.
PROFESSOR: Great.
So, 90 degrees.
All right.
So this is all straightforward
when we're just thinking about
different molecular shapes that
don't have any lone pairs
in them, but once we start
having lone pairs, we now need
to think about how those
lone pairs are going
to affect the geometry.
But before we do that, let's
talk about some examples of
molecules without lone pairs.
So the first case is what we saw
at the beginning of class,
carbon dioxide, and we said that
that was linear, and now
we know why it's linear -- it
has a formula of a x 2, and an
s n number of 2.
And that's a bond angle
of 180 degrees.
So, you can tell us about
borane, borane is a x 3.
PROFESSOR: And what
is the geometry?
And the angle?
120.
Feel free to yell out very
loudly, we want people in
OpenCourseWare to hear the
answers coming from the room.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So the next case we're going
to look at is c h 4 or
methane, and let's do a clicker
question here to make
sure everyone is remembering
these geometries.
And this should be very quick,
and try to not turn the page
back one, and tell us in
10 seconds here what
the geometry is.
98%, that is a new record.
Very good.
Tetrahedral.
PROFESSOR: All right, while I'm
holding carbon dioxide in
one hand and methane in the
other hand, I just want to do
an additional plug for the
energy debate tonight.
So there will be representatives
from both
presidential campaigns that
are going to be there to
answer questions.
And I'm not sure of the exact
format, I'm not sure whether
all audience members are
going to be able to ask
questions or not.
I'm not sure if I'm going to be
there, I'm supposed to be
giving a talk actually,
ironically, about energy at
the same time.
But if I can't make it and
you're allowed to ask
questions, I'd like you to
ask a question for me.
So, my lab looks at enzymes that
remove carbon monoxide
and carbon dioxide from
the environment.
And I have an energy initiative
grant to do this,
because MIT recognizes that an
important part of any energy
initiative is thinking about
lowering pollutants and
greenhouse gases.
So, I heard on Thursday at the
debate when Governor Sarah
Palin was asked directly if
she really doesn't think
there's any connection between
global warming and any
man-made activities, that she
said, well, you know, it could
be just regular temperature
fluctuations, and she doesn't
want to point any fingers.
So, she's not quite sure.
I also learned on Thursday that
she will head the energy
initiative in a McCain/Palin
White House.
So, if you go to this debate,
I would like you to ask what
is your plan for sequestering
carbon dioxide and other
greenhouse gases.
You can ask both candidates,
and please let me know what
the answer is, because I think
that's a really important
question -- here we have carbon
dioxide, here we have
methane, we need to be thinking
about greenhouse gases.
PROFESSOR: You can also throw
in the question that you do
know this is tetrahedral
and 109 .
5 degrees -- show your chemistry
knowledge here.
All right, and let's keep
showing that we know our
geometries, let's
look at p c l 5.
PROFESSOR: And what
is geometry here?
Yup.
And the angles?
120 and 90.
PROFESSOR: So, 120 equatorial,
and 90 axial.
And last we have s f 6.
PROFESSOR: So, what is
the geometry here?
Octahedral.
And angle?
90.
PROFESSOR: All right, so there's
our set of examples,
one for each for those shapes
or geometries that have no
lone pairs.
And now let's think a little
bit about once we do have
molecules with lone pairs.
And the biggest point to keep
in mind when we're comparing
lone pair electrons with bonding
electrons or electrons
in bonds, is that when you have
electrons in bonds they
have less spatial distribution
than lone pairs.
So that's just a way of saying
that electrons and bonds, they
take up less space.
So, when we think about lone
pair electrons, they're taking
up more space and this means
that they're going to
experience more repulsion in
thinking about the lone pair
electrons with either other lone
pair electrons or with
bonding electrons.
So let's think a second
about the order that
this will be in.
The biggest repulsion we would
feel is if we have two
different lone pair electrons
or lone pairs.
They're going to have
the most repulsion.
In the middle is if we're
talking about a lone pair with
a bonding pair.
And then the least repulsion
is going to be between two
bonds or two bonding
pairs of electrons.
So, let's look at an example
of where this comes up.
So the first example I'm going
to talk about is a molecule
that has the geometry of a
seesaw shape, and once we get
to having Professor Drennan
actually show you that shape,
you will never forget.
See-saw, that's going to
be one of the easy
geometries to remember.
But the first thing that we need
to consider in terms of
the shape, which starts, if you
picture first of all, and
these models sometimes don't
quite stay together, we could
actually have two different
possibilities.
The first is the idea that we
could have an axial lone pair,
and the second is the
possibility that we could have
an equatorial lone pair.
And we could consider both, and
we should be able to use
our vsper principles to think
about which one is actually
going to happen.
So if we think about having an
axial lone pair here, that
would mean that these lone pair
electrons are going to be
within 90 degrees of three
different loan pairs, and
actually we'll see later, it
will be more than 90 because
they're actually going
to push them down.
But in terms of considering
how many bonding electron
pairs they'll repel strongly,
what we care about is anything
within 90 degrees initially.
So, what we would see with the
axial lone pair is that we
have three lone pairs
that we're going to
very strongly repel.
Now would you tell me, if we
think about an equatorial lone
pair, how many different bonding
electrons or a bonding
pairs that will strongly
repel if we have an
equatorial lone pair?
So you might need to look at
your notes to actually compare
these two before you submit
your answer up here.
All right.
Let's take 10 seconds on that.
OK, strong showing with the
clicker questions today.
It's going to be a tight race
for clicker competition.
It's correct that the equatorial
is, in fact, has
two, only two that it
strongly repels.
So, actually it's probably
easier to look at Professor
Drennan's model here
to see that.
So it's where the equatorial
lone pair is that is the
actual seesaw geometry.
PROFESSOR: So, how many of you
had seesaws in playgrounds
when you were growing up?
Oh, a lot of people.
I know that they're not
considered totally safe
anymore, so some of them
are going away.
So this is seesaw.
Now you should never
forget it.
PROFESSOR: All right, so seesaw,
we've got seesaw.
Just to point out a
few more shapes.
We took one out, we replaced one
bond with a lone pair in
terms of seesaw.
If we have a x 3 e
2 now we have two
equatorial lone pairs.
This is called the T-shaped
PROFESSOR: T-shaped.
PROFESSOR: See, these aren't
too hard to remember the
geometries, the geometry
names.
And we also can think about
if we have a x 4 e 2.
So now in order to get our lone
pairs as far away from
each other as possible, they're
going to be on the
axial position, and this is
called square planer.
PROFESSOR: So, this is easy to
remember, square, also planar.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So, let's talk a little bit
now about what the actual
angles are between bonds
when now we have
these lone pairs present.
And remember, what we said is
when we have a lone pair of
electrons, they actually are
going to have more repulsion
than if we just have
a c h bond or a
bonded pair of a electrons.
So essentially what that means
is that in molecules that have
lone pair electrons, so for
example, if we look at n h 3
or ammonia versus methane here,
and Professor Drennan is
showing those models
to you here.
What you end up seeing is
actually that the bonding
angle in n h 3 between the
n h bonds is smaller.
And you can't see it with these
models because these are
not actual lone pairs.
But if they were actually
repelling each other, they
would be pushing those bonds as
far away as possible, and
instead of being 109 .
5, you'd see that the
angle is now 106 .
7.
So it's a smaller angle between
bonds, because you
have more repulsion from
those lone pairs
pushing those bonds down.
We can also think about the
influence of atomic size in
terms of this effect.
So first of all, what happens to
atomic size as you go down
the periodic table?
Good, it increases.
So we have size increasing as we
go down the periodic table.
Phosphorous is right underneath
nitrogen on the
periodic table, so phosphorous
is going to
be bigger than nitrogen.
In terms of picturing what
happens with those lone pairs,
when we have a larger atom, the
orbitals are also going to
be larger, they can take
up more space.
That means these electrons, this
lone pair electrons are
going to take up more space.
This means they're going to
push away those bonding
electrons even more.
So would you expect the
bond to be larger or
smaller for p h 3?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's going
to be smaller.
So, what we see is that angles
between bonded atoms actually
decrease as you go down a column
on the periodic table.
So the actual angles for p h 3
are now going to be really
quite a bit smaller,
they're 93 .
3 degrees.
All right.
So let's create a list for
ourselves in terms of all the
geometries that we can have now
that we're dealing with
lone pairs.
One thing I want to point out
in terms of remembering the
names of the different
geometries, when you're naming
a geometry, the geometry name,
for example, when we looked at
square planar, we're only
actually naming where the
bonds are, where actual
atoms are.
The name doesn't really depend
on the lone pairs.
And also, when you draw a
geometry, you don't always
have to draw the lone pairs in,
but you have to remember
that the lone pairs are very
much affecting the angles
within your molecule and
also the actual shape.
So, for example, let's start
talking about different types
that have lone pairs in it.
First of all, thinking about a
x 2 e, so we have one lone
pair, and the geometry here is
bent, and I want you, thinking
about lone pair repulsion, to
tell us what you think the
angle between these bonds
are going to be?
And let's take 10
seconds on that.
OK, good.
75%, that's not bad.
Let's think about why.
It's going to be less than 120
degrees, because we know that
normally in a trigonal planar
situation, we have an angle of
120 degrees.
And since lone pairs are going
to cause more repulsion, we're
actually pushing down these
two bonds here closer
together, so what we end up
seeing is that they're going
to be less than 120 degrees.
And it depends on the actual
molecule what the exact angles
are going to be, so you never
have to learn the exact angles
in terms of lone pair electrons,
you just need to be
able to tell us if the bond
angle is going to be less than
120 degrees.
So let's look at another example
here, a x 3 with one
lone pair, e.
This is called trigonal
pyramidal.
Again, you have trigonal because
there's three atoms
bonded to the central
atom, and this looks
like a pyramid here.
PROFESSOR: So, what would
the angle of this be?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I think I heard it.
PROFESSOR: I think so, too.
Less than 109 .
5.
Let's take another example,
a x 2 e 2.
This is also bent.
Tell us what the geometry -- we
told you the geometry, tell
us what the bond angle
is going to be
between these bonds.
So, let's take 10
seconds on this.
Let's re-poll F 4.
So 10 seconds again.
All right.
In about 10 seconds, Darcy,
in 10 seconds we'll
hit the next side.
OK, so it's less than 109 .
5 degrees now.
So some of you wrote that it was
less than 120 degrees, and
we can think about if we switch
back to the class notes
the difference here.
So even though, so this is now
going to be less than 109 .
5, if we looked at the case we
had bent in the first case,
that started with 120 and one
of those bonds was replaced
with a lone pair, but now we
have two lone pairs here, so
now what we're going to see is
that the two bents are not, in
fact, equal.
The bent where you started with
the tetrahedral shape is
actually going to be
less than 109 .
5, and Professor Drennan can
maybe show us that with the
models here.
PROFESSOR: It's a little had to
see, actually, between the
two, but I think it's easier
to see on this, that if you
consider the sort of starting
place for the two, if you look
at the bottom set and you put
orbitals, so it also depends
on your starting geometry.
It can be bent if take off these
bonds on the top, but it
depends on what the starting
geometries were.
And so you will go with your
starting geometry,
if it was 109 .
5, it'll be less than that.
If it's 120, then it's
less than that.
PROFESSOR: So, this is a good
case of where, even when you
have the geometry the same, you
need to think about how
many lone pairs you're dealing
with in your molecule, and
think about what would the
geometry be if I just pictured
those lone pairs in there as
bonds and then push them even
closer together so that it's
less than that actual angle.
OK, let's talk about a x 4 e,
and that is what we call the
seesaw shape.
PROFESSOR: And so, what
difference in angles are you
going to have?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yup.
PROFESSOR 2: So, two sets again,
one is less than 120,
and one is going to
be less than 90.
So, let's look at a x 3 e 2,
you'll notice there's a lot
more combinations we can get
to once we're talking about
lone pairs.
This is called T-shaped, and we
had briefly discussed that
but not mention what the
angles would be.
PROFESSOR: So, what angle
would you have here?
Yup.
PROFESSOR: All right, great.
Less than 90 degrees.
So, we'll start a new page here
and talk about a x 2 e 3,
and we'll let you tell us
what this geometry is.
Yup, so I hear a lot of
linear out there.
And you need to keep in mind
we give the names based on
where the actual bonds are, not
where the lone pairs are,
even though the lone pairs, of
course, affect the structure
in the geometry.
PROFESSOR: The angle?
STUDENT: 180.
PROFESSOR: Yup, 180.
PROFESSOR: So, it's exactly
180 here, not less than.
PROFESSOR: So, for a x 5 e, what
we have here is called
square pyramidal.
This is square because of the
four square at the bottom of
your pyramid, then you can
picture the pyramid as you go
to the top.
PROFESSOR: And so what angles
would you have here?
Yup, less than 90.
PROFESSOR: So, less
than 90, great.
All right, there are more.
So, our next combination that
we can think about is if we
have four bonded atoms and two
lone pairs, a x 4 e 2, that's
going to be called
square planar.
PROFESSOR: So, again, we have
square and it's planar.
And so what are your
angles here?
Yup, exactly 90.
PROFESSOR: So next let's
look at a x 3 e 3.
This is what we call T-shape,
this is also T-shape.
PROFESSOR: And angle here?
PROFESSOR: Yup, I think we heard
less than, it's less
than 90 degrees.
And let's look at a x 2 e 4, and
again, you guys can tell
us what this geometry
is, first of all.
Yup, it's linear.
So, we have lots of different
ways we can get to a linear
molecule, some of which have
lots of lone pairs, some of
which have no lone
pairs at all.
This is linear and
a 180 degrees.
All right.
So we'll do just a few examples
to show you some
actual molecules that have
these geometries.
We won't go through all of
them, because as we saw,
there's lots of different
combinations we can have once
we start getting into
lone pairs.
The first we'll look at is water
here, and water is a
good one to look at because we
had seen that at the beginning
of class here when
we were talking
about all polar molecules.
When we talk about the formula
type of water, what when you
say the formula type is?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: A x 2 e 2,
that's correct.
And what is the geometry
of water?
It's bent.
So what we saw at the beginning
of class is water is
bent and now you can see why and
should be able to predict
that yourself.
I just want to mention that if
you look, and depending on the
edition of the book you have,
in one edition it's called
bent, in the other edition
it's called angular.
We'll call it bent, but just
remember that bent and
angular, they're the
same geometry.
Let's look at another
example, s f 4.
And here it is drawn here.
What is the formula
type for s f 4?
I think I heard it, a x 4 e.
And the geometry?
Seesaw, good.
All right, we never get seesaw
wrong, that's the easy
give-away one.
All right, what about b r f 3?
This is the shape here.
What is the geometry for b f 3
-- the original geometry, not
the new geometry here?
What was that?
STUDENT: T.
PROFESSOR: T-shaped,
that's right.
B f 3 is T-shaped.
All right, so let's
look at xenon f 2.
That's going to have a formula
type of a x 2 e 3, if we
actually look at the Lewis
structure here.
So if you think about what the
geometry is, and you should
just be able to look at this
and see, what would you say
the geometry of xenon f 2 is?
STUDENT: Linear.
PROFESSOR: Linear, good.
All right.
And let's try one more here,
which is a x 4 e 2, or a xenon
f 4 -- very explosive,
but a good example.
STUDENT: Square planar.
PROFESSOR: Square planar,
all right, great.
So, in general, when we think
about vsper theory, even
though it doesn't talk about or
tell us anything about the
energies of these different
shapes, it's very useful in
making a first approximation
and coming very close to
thinking about what the actual
shapes of molecules are.
So one thing I want to point
out in terms of what you're
responsible for is you should
be able to fill out one of
these charts with only seeing
the labels up here -- tell us
the formula type, tell us the
steric number, tell us the
geometry, you should be able to
draw the Lewis structure,
you already know how to
do that, and also
talk about the angles.
So, as you finish up your
problem-set, you can, I think
now, get through just
about all of it.
You can do now this part
with the geometry.
So, we'll see you on Wednesday
-- we're going to get out a
little bit early today.